vegetables are such an asset in the
kitchen healthy fantastically fresh and
incredibly versatile and pound-for-pound
there's so much cheaper than fish or
meat just make sure you give them plenty
of attitude my first recipe is so quick
and easy
but seriously impressive and deceptively
cheap homemade gnocchi making your own
yaki is so simple to do yet the results
are absolutely stunning and it's a great
way of using up leftover baked potatoes
you can make no key just with flour and
eggs however the procedure gives it a
nice light sort of creamy fluffy texture
let's cut them in half to your spoon and
scoop the inside of those potatoes I'm
using leftover baked potatoes but this
really works as well with leftover ball
potatoes two choices and get a fork and
sort of mash the potatoes and get it
nice and light and fluffy or this little
gadget it's called a ricer I suppose
it's a posh word for a potato masher
just squeeze gently you can see how nice
and light it is almost like fluffy
little strands of potato you can do this
one potatoes are hot it'll go through
the rice is so much quicker just slice
that off there now a nice spoon of a
kosarin don't touch a salt and pepper
it's really important to season the
mixture to go along otherwise the naki
becomes really bland flour over the
ricotta sieve there's no lumps one
delicious egg give that a little whisk
now make a little well in the center you
want a nice soft pie ball the ball of
dough give that a really good mix get
some thyme flowers in there
and this time is like fragrant that's
just a really nice herb and with the
ricotta to taste brilliant just pick the
little tips the time flowers next flour
your hands generously and knead the
mixture into a dough fold in and push
from basically what it's doing is to get
it nice and smooth as it starts to get a
little bit wet just that little touch of
flour but once I make really nice and
soft now don't overwork it it stops to
knock you from expanding when it hits
the pan that's exactly what I want a
nice sort of soft fragrant ball cut the
ball in half lightly flour the hands and
just roll it gently I just think of a a
big long cigar the mixture will start
getting a little bit sort of wetter but
do not add lots of flour now lightly
flour the knife so when you slice the
Nakia it doesn't stick to cut the dough
into bite-sized pieces just take your
finger dip it in the flour and push to
help why I want mine Aki's you look like
a pillow and for me the most important
part there is that not one of them I
identity the same shape go on bring up
to the boil little touch of olive oil in
there lightly flour your hand lift up
the no key in the rolling boiling water
turn that pan stop them I'm sticking on
the bottom and let them simmer and they
start to sort of tell you they're cooked
when they start floating got a pan on
get that nice and hot now that just
started to come to the top and you can
continue cooking them like that I like
blanch them in the water take them out
and then find them 2:30 the naki heat
olive oil in a frying pan gently lift up
and look they've doubled in size drain
it get rid of the excess water and
straight in to the hot pan
[Music]
this is where they start to take on a
completely different texture nice crisp
sauteed texture on the outside not he
loves fresh pepper
so pepper in and you see as I start
telling them got this really nice little
sort of brown color are they almost
popping up now my little parcels so on
the nice associate both sides of lights
and creamy in the center fresh garden
peas in the butter gives it that really
nice sort of beurre noisette flavor on
the ends
beautiful but little bit of fresh thyme
over the peas and then finally I want to
lift it up fresh lemon zest the lemon
over smells incredible and then finally
seal the deal with a touch of grated
Parmesan cheese give you veg term
attitude and you'll get amazingly
elegant dishes on a budget that are
always guaranteed to impress what more
do you want from great cooking cheap to
make easy to cook and absolutely
stunning cooking great food doesn't mean
you have to spend a fortune on fancy
equipment get some basic essentials and
you'll be set in the kitchen
saucepans me basically you don't need a
collection of 10 we need weenies to a
medium-sized one followed by a large one
a small pans great for sources heating
liquids or rice whereas your large pan
gives you space perfect for pastas
choose or when you're cooking in bulk
which keeps cost down made from copper
to stainless steel fine what's right for
you and always get a lid which helps
heat the pan up as quickly as possible
and the secret behind a great saucepan
is the heavier the bottom the more heat
will conduct the thinner the bottom
the more charge you've got actually
burning with food by the best sauce
spoons you can afford take good care of
them and the last two years saving you
money in the long run
amazing recipes don't necessarily have
to include meat cooking vegetarian
dishes will reduce your food bills
without compromising on taste and flavor
here are three more recipes to satisfy
even the keenest carnivore like me that
will max out on veg and won't break the
bank
[Applause]
starting with spicy black beans with
feta and avocado
[Music]
first in a pan heat olive oil and
chopped onion and fry until soft then
finely sliced garlic and chili
at cumin
cinnamon and black beans then combined
cook together until deliciously soft
these small beans come dried or in tins
and there are great chief ingredient to
make dishes more substantial to serve
dollop the black bean mixture and
crunchy tortillas top with cube ripe
avocado chopped fresh coriander and
crumbled salty feta cheese
spicy black beans with feta and avocado
a dish as filling Google and tastes
fantastic
my next great veg recipe is linking
Greer rusty with fried eggs
[Music]
in a hot pan sweat shredded leeks along
with a knob of butter and season next
great Powerball potatoes and Greer a
hard Swiss cheese with a great nutty
flavor
then combined with a soft release in a
pan heat oil and a little butter
spooning the potato leek and cheese mix
cook gently until golden and crisp
underneath and then slide onto a plate
flip over and return to the pan to
finish cooking
[Music]
finally for the perfect topping fry two
eggs and place them on top of the Rasta
top with fresh tarragon
[Music]
leaking kriya rusty with fried eggs are
simple but substantial dish that makes
the most of hearty root veg addition
takes as much time to write on a
blackboard as it does to cook chickpea
cumin and spinach kofta with tahini
dressing in a blender put team chickpeas
cumin seeds paprika and turmeric and
blessed to a paste
[Music]
next we'll spinach in olive oil and chop
finely then add to the chickpea mixture
sprinkle in gram flour made from finely
ground chickpeas then shaped golf ball
sized chunks of the mixture using a
spoon and rest in the fridge when ready
to cook heat oil in a frying pan shallow
fry the koftas until golden brown on all
sides then rest them on kitchen paper to
absorb any excess oil for an easy
dipping sauce mix yogurt with a dollop
of tahini and a squeeze of lemon and
stir in freshly chopped coriander
a mouth-watering dish that's perfect for
sharing chick feed cumin and spinach
kofta with tahini dressing
three amazing recipes with fantastic veg
proof that even if you're cooking on a
budget you can still eat like a king and
when it comes to buying potatoes a great
ingredient if you're cooking on a budget
one green grocer who can always spot a
dud spud is borough market royalty Fred
foster it's all about flavor it's all
about choosing the right variety for the
right fish he's been selling top-quality
veg for over fifteen years and really
knows the king edward's from his Duke of
York's basically there's two types of
potatoes there's early season and a main
crop rotation early season is basically
round about May time you can't store
them they cannot be stored you have to
buy them and use them within two to
three days when you're buying an early
season potato you must avoid green
looking potatoes at all costs it really
is important and the way you can tell
that is if you just brush the potato the
skin comes off really really easy and
then you want you want to yellowy or
whitey look invitation the new season
potato is a super potato to use new
season types include Rocket Home Guard
and Maris barn but my favorite is the
classic Jersey boil it has a delicate
sweet flavor
it's packed with vitamin C and is great
in salads or simply boiled and mixed
with olive oil and fresh mint jersey but
say is early crop are phenomenal
look at that keep the skin on it's
really important just wash it boil it
it's a beautiful beautiful potato and
that's what we're talking about we're
talking about I know it's a potato I
know it's a bit sad but we're talking
about flavor right then what is the main
crop potato it's the crop that is grown
specifically for nine months of the year
use when you're looking at a main crop
potato you need to see that the eyes
aren't too large because they tend to go
right through the potato they've got to
be firm it's very very important if a
potato in any way feels a little bit
soft discard it storage wise dark place
cold place dry a place and that will
last till you
simple as that both early-season and
main crop potatoes come in two main
types waxy and flowery waxy potatoes
have a smooth dense flesh and because
they're low in starch they stay firm
when cooked types include a neo and pink
fur but I love Charlotte which has an
amazing buttery taste and her great aid
in stews or served whole with roast
chicken flour potatoes have a fluffy dry
texture when cooked which makes them
great for mashing roasting or cutting
into chips types include King Edward
whose smooth creamy flesh is perfect for
potato gratins
or with rich meats like beef and dairy
which have an amazing red skin and are
great for baking or is delicious potato
wedges old-fashioned types known as
heritage potatoes are now widely
available and fantastic colors and
distinctive taste that are great when
you want something different
this one's called salad blue when you
cut it you then see the most amazing
color and it's perfectly looks stunning
on the plate a really popular it's so
important when you're going out to pick
your potatoes you already know in
advance what you're going to do with
them at a time so whether you're going
to put it in a salad where it's a masher
or a chip or even a baking potato each
variety has a unique flavor
Fred spot-on weather new season main
crop waxy or floury potatoes are
incredibly versatile and packed with
great flavor the perfect ingredient when
you're cooking on a budget well how much
do I love to say as well cook them
simply proper flavors it doesn't get any
better
[Music]
like all chefs for me there's nothing
better than seasonal produce at its peak
when fruit and vegies fresh in season
and fantastically ripe I can't wait to
get back in the kitchen to get the most
out of your cooking always use
ingredients in their prime
my next recipe is a proper British
classic that super simple to cook and
cost next nothing and delicious apple
crumble crumbles are the perfect waves
used through when it's in season there's
lots of about is nice and cheap but most
importantly the fruits at its absolute
best
first off I'm gonna make a really nice
light Carol pan on ice and low great to
apples and this helps that almost sort
of purely apples so much quicker a lot
of flavor in the skin so don't worry
about peeling the fruit whether it's
pears plums peaches flavors in the skin
nice start the camera a couple of
tablespoons of sugar the sugar helps to
get rid of tartness in the apple a touch
of cinnamon that starts to make it a
little spicy
open up your vanilla just scrape out all
those seeds now this just makes it light
and fragrant all those seeds in to the
sugar we're making caramel be patient
and always swirl the dish instead of
stirring it when the sugar goes Brown
add the apple
that starts to sort of cool down the
camel but it gives it a really nice sort
of caramelized pureed apples almost
disintegrating smells incredible turn
the gas down slice up two apples
it's a crumble that's got no frills
straightforward and faffing around I'm
peeling of the skin
I don't meant to sort of stand out from
the camera apples in now there's nice
thick chunks of Apple sort of almost
bending itself into the puree dried
cranberries gives it that nice sort of
shock in the texture sweet and chewy I
wanted to sort of taste
zesty spicy so set the lemon zest on top
of your apples and cranberry fresh lemon
juice over and that just gives that
extra acidic kick takes the cranberries
the apples the camel and the cinnamon to
another level
turn the gas off there that sits and
let's concentrate and the crumble flour
in I cut the tablespoons of Demerara
sugar sugar helps to get the topping
nice and crispy butter in give that a
nice little filling rub looking for is
like a breadcrumb mixture lightly
seasoned it with a touch of cinnamon
and the Demerara sugar sort of helps to
get a nice fine crumble mix now it stops
the butter I'm sort of melting in that
flour so that's the basic crumble mix
but I'm not finished yet
music two-thirds crumble one-third music
mix that in if you haven't got muesli
and crunchy granola works brilliantly -
lovely now start off in the center and
work your way around
I want the crispy nuts on the top the
puree on the bottom of the camera and
then the texture in the center a good
tip turn the gas back on want it
bubbling before it goes in the oven
because then you just got to cook the
top so as soon as you see that caramel
start the bubble down the side in she
goes let's go
make it to two degrees Celsius for 12 to
14 minutes until golden brown smells
amazing
[Music]
beautiful still bubbling and look at it
a delicious but very simple crumble with
apples at their absolute best beautiful
[Music]
next my tricks the trade and kitchen
tips
first up cooking pasta a great budget
basic to keep in the cupboard it can be
easily undercooked or overcooked here's
how to do it properly
first water Lynn nice large pan to make
sure that passes got sufficient room to
cook evenly
nicely seasons absolutely crucial olive
all in that stops the pasta from
sticking together bring up to the ball
that's the rolling boil the secret there
it stops the pass from sticking together
and it gently rolls it around now this
is angel passed a nice thin pasta takes
three to four minutes so into the pan as
it hits the water it melts and then you
turn it round tongs as that starts to
melt gently twist that into the pan
bring it back up to the boil if your
better timing then set a timer beautiful
to test it lift a little strand and you
actually feed it with your fingers it's
still nice and firm mmm I'll then take
not a bite not a strong wine but just
really nice and firm inside definitely
not crunchy and then into a colander
drain the pasta in a light seasoning
salt and pepper a tablespoon of olive
oil mix that through that stops it from
sticking together and look there you go
beautiful pasta al dente
a tip for making the most of spare bread
blitz leftovers into breadcrumbs great
for stuffing or crab cakes or cut into
chunks some fries for perfect croutons
on demand or simply terre news in a
delicious rustic salad dried pulses like
chickpeas or lentils are great for soups
and stews and toss pennies but don't
season them until the end of the cooking
or the salt makes them go tough for
perfect ball potatoes always start them
off with cold water and never born in
water this way by the time the center's
of the potatoes are cooked the outside
won't be falling apart and when you're
cooking potatoes always cook extra so
there's leftovers there fantastic to
have on hand for making my delicious
gnocchi and potato rust-eze or a classic
bubble and squeak
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course pack
with key lessons top tips and 100
recipes to stake your life on and you'll
literally be cooking yourself into a
better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the App Store for
details go on